قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الوزير انطوني
بلينكن طلب في اتصال هاتفيا اجره مناظيرها
الروسي سرغي لافروف بالافراج الفوري عن
صحفي
المعتقل في روسيا اضافت الخارجيه
الامريكيه
ايضا ضروره ايجاد مناخ يسمح للبعثات
الدبلوماسيه باداء مهامها من جانبها اكدت
الخارجيه الروسيه ان لافروف شدد خلال
الاتصال على رفض موسكو تسييسا قضيه اعتقال
مراسل صحيفه
ان المراسل ضبط متلبسا وان القضاء سيحدد
مصيره
وكان جهاز امن الدوله الفيدرالي الروسيه
اعتقل
ايفانل الامريكيه في منطقه الاورال واتهمه
بتنفيذ مهمه او اكلتها له الولايات
المتحده لجمع معلومات عن احدى منشات
التصنيع العسكري الروسي ومحاوله الحصول
على وثائق تتضمن معلومات سريه
[تصفيق]
من جديد تنضم الينا مراسله الجزيره رانيا
دريدي من دونيتسك
اذا رانيا ماذا في التفاصيل المتعلقه بهذا
الاتصال
وكيفيه تعامل موسكو مع قضيه اعتقال صحفي
موس
بدايه لا بد من الاشاره لانه وفقا
للخارجيه روسيه فان هذه المكالمه التي جرت
اليوم بين وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ونظيره
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن جاءت هذه المكالمه
الهاتفيه بمبادره من قبل الجانب الامريكي
نعم تم التطرق الى بعض المسائل المتعلقه
الملحه المتعلقه بالعلاقات الثنائيه ولكن
انطلاقا مما صدر عن الخارجيه الروسيه من
الواضح ان التركيز الاكبر كان على قضيه
وملف صحفي
في هذا الشان اشارت الخارجيه الى ان وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه
خلال هذه المكالمه على ضروره ان يحترم
الجانب الامريكي لقرارات السلطات الروسيه
والتي هي قائمه بحسب الخارجيه على اساس
القانون الروسي وعلى الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
التزامات روسيا
الدوليه فضلا عن ذلك نقطه اخرى تم عليها
وهي مساله تسييس هذا الملف الخارجيه
الروسيه اشارت الى ان موسكو كانت واضحه
خلال هذه المكالمه شددت على ان مساله
تسييس هذه هذا الملف من قبل الجانب
الامريكي من قبل وسائل الاعلام الغربيه
ويعد امرا غير مقبول به كونه تم اعتقال
هذا الصحفي متلبسا خلال عمليه جمعه
لمعلومات سريه جمع بيانات تعد اسرار
للدوله وقد تم اعتقاله وهو متلبس وعليه
فان هذا الصحفي بحسب الجانب الروسي سيتم
تم اعتقاله تم اعتقاله وفقا للاجراءات
المعمول بها لدى السلطات الروسيه ووفقا
للقانون الروسي وقد تم اخطار السفاره
الامريكيه لدى موسكو بكل الاجراءات التي
تم اتخاذها ازاء هذا الصحفي وفي هذا الشان
اشار لابروف خلال هذه المكالمه الى ان
مصير هذا الصحفي سيحدده القضاء الروسي
رانيا
ينضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره محمد
العلمي للمزيد بشان هذا الموضوع اذا محمد
وفق الجانب الروسي موضوع الصحفي صحفي
جورنال متروك للقضاء الروسي كيف ستتعامل
الولايات المتحده مع ذلك وما هي خياراتها
ليست هناك خيارات كثيره امام البيت الابيض
ربما باستثناء طرد دبلوماسيين روس كما دعا
الى ذلك نائب الرئيس السابق مايك بانس
واحد المرشحين المحتملين في الانتخابات
القادمه طبعا اعتقال صحفي امريكي احظى
باهتمام الراي العام هنا في الولايات
المتحده باهتمام الحكومه الامريكيه وايضا
باهتمام تغطيه زملائه الصحفيين الذين
يشهدون له بانه كان صحفيا او ما زال صحفيا
مهنيا وانه ضبط متلبسا بالقيام بعمله
الصحفي حسب محطه ام بي سي انه كان يعد
تقريرا عن مشاعر او المشاعر الحقيقيه
للروس ازاء الحرب في اوكرانيا وتقرير عن
مجموعه فاجنر ويبدو انه سال اسئله الاسئله
الخطا خلال هذه التغطيه الصحافيه والتي
ادت الى